i'm laura ingram this is the ingram
angle from washington tonight thank you
for joining us
all right right off the bat we got old
mcbiden saw a farm that's the focus of
tonight's angle
all right put your mind at rest people
stop worrying about soaring food and
energy costs because
today joe biden's on the case
he visited a farm
it was part listening tour
every day that gets pushed back
push back
yes and we usually run out of growing
season you know so we can't we can't
control that i can typically produce
about 60 percent as a double crop
but yeah there's still always risk
involved that i'm burying by myself
a couple things that i wanted to be able
to to
talk about here what we had just walked
through back there
yep part meaningless small talk
[Music]
this one working there you go
please sit down
one of things i want to put to rest
everybody looks at me and says
have you ever been on a farm
and i remind them that nobody but nobody
knows i come from the state of delaware
single largest industry in delaware and
the delmarva of delaware maryland
virginia peninsula that peninsula that
goes down
is agriculture
thank you rand mcnally and more talk of
spending money that we don't have
earlier this year the u.s department of
agriculture announced it would invest
250 million dollars to boost fertilizer
production
literally on the plane out here on air
force one i turned to tom and i said tom
double that make it 500 million it's so
desperately needed
why stop there
well what's desperately needed though is
a president who doesn't offer fake
empathy when what we need are real
solutions
but fake empathy is all he can offer and
it's exactly what we got when he went on
to chicago
i come from a family
and i mean it sincerely like most of you
where the price of gasoline went up
significantly the price of food went up
that's what we talked about at the
dinner table the kitchen table i
couldn't afford daycare i i couldn't
afford child care not a joke
i was making forty two thousand dollars
a year which was a lot of money as a us
senator
i couldn't afford it
thank god i got a big family
my dad would say family's the beginning
middle in the end
then biden tried to make you feel better
about the disaster state of our economy
and our lower standard of living by
comparing life at the height of the
pandemic to the days of biden
infrastructure bucks
we gave them a whole lot of money
we added back 460 000 jobs
critical state local workers educators
firefighters police officers remember
those long lines you'd see in a
television
people lining up in all kinds of
vehicles just to get a box of food how
quickly you forget
and what did the mica crowd want to do
forget it
forget it people would have to wait in
line an hour or hour and a half to get a
box of food
and they're trunk
it's just unbelievable
do his speechwriters not see the irony
here
a few hours earlier he gave a speech
about inflation in rising prices a food
and gas of course more than 43 up now
costs that are due to his policies
but perhaps the white house missed this
headline
about how inflation is so bad that some
women say they're skipping meals now in
order to meet their family's food budget
but none of what biden is doing is going
to make any difference
his move to release the 30 million
barrels from our strategic petroleum
reserve was worse than a flop it's now
compromising our national security by
depleting our energy source that was
being saved for emergencies
meanwhile if that's not enough the white
house is planning to further erode our
economic position vis-a-vis china
the globalists inside the bite
administration are on the verge of
convincing scranton joe to help the ccp
by dropping trump's tariffs
and apparently for that great deal
america will get nothing
now remember china is so sleazy it's so
dishonest
it hasn't even lived up to its phase one
agreement to buy 200 billion dollars
worth of agricultural products from us
it obviously knew that with trump out
it's when they agreed to it when trump
jumps out they could welch on the
bargain and there'd be no consequences
under biden
so how bad will this be
well already with trump's tariffs in
place
china is on pace to enjoy a trade
surplus of over 400 billion dollars with
the u.s this year alone
so the way things look
biden is simply going to declare that
that whole tariff thing was a mistake
that just contributed to higher prices
for all consumers
somehow though biden thinks that he can
mollify americans concerns about china
with vapid comments masquerading as
tough talk
and he said
he was talking about why america is a
diminishing power
and i said mr president
it's never been a good bet to bet
against the american people
no one's ever won betting against
american people
he was talking to president xi there
but the truth is america needs to begin
the arduous process of decoupling from
that murderous bunch that runs china
it's time we pull back our essential
manufacturing because
the true cost of our dependence on this
repressive regime is already being felt
and baby formula shortages drug
shortages and now
shortages in iv contrast fluid in
hospitals
johns hopkins has sent a letter to all
of its staff that the cause of the
shortage is the covet pandemic but of
course the real cause is the shanghai
lockdown
turns out shanghai is where much of the
iv fluid is produced
this is terrifying it has to change
we can't be held hostage by china or the
one worlders here in the u.s who sold us
out for so long
so today's trip to the farm was just
another desperate act
an act that was poorly choreographed by
the white house coms team
they really think this is all just a
messaging problem don't they that
americans are stupid
so stupid as to believe that any of
biden's gestures will fundamentally
alter the economic plight that they see
before them
but the people of this great country
they're smarter than the elites think
and if they could right now yeah they'd
send biden and all of his enablers back
to the farm and permanently out to
pasture
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else